in five four three two uno hello
everybody welcome to another genius
brain podcast how are you doing today
my name is Debbie co-hosting with man me
almost is like George it's a cow right
now it looks like there's two chinos on
the TV screen but actually is like we're
really not and like welcome to genius
brain because it's [ __ ] awesome and
we have our hombre Cali boy sorry a [ __ ]
for that we this will grew up in LA and
I look Mexican sources you know my
friend he's he's Japanese and his his
family's like full-blooded Japanese but
they're they don't speak Japanese to
only speak Spanish and they're actually
Mexican so like so yeah I call this a
case of bad timing so they decided to
take a trip to Mexico their ancestors
right to go to Mexico before they came
into America so they were gonna go visit
Mexico as Japanese immigrants and all
this [ __ ] and then World War two
happened oh all of their Japanese family
members in California we're like don't
come here they're [ __ ] rounding us up
in caps and [ __ ] and they're like well
[ __ ] it already by then you know
it's [ __ ] Mexico right okay so they
just stayed there for like three
generations or whatever the [ __ ] you're
like like I think their grandparents
came down raise their right raise theirs
parents all that they don't speak no
Japanese they speak Spanish so there'll
be email Mexican restaurants and if they
talk and [ __ ] they're like [ __ ]
I understand that's [ __ ] crazy
because they couldn't go back to Japan
cuz the [ __ ] did they not know what was
going on in the world I think they just
I said bad timing man like you shouldn't
alev I mean it's good that they left
Japan you know because they would have
been [ __ ] up yeah I think it's isn't
it ironic how Mexico was probably a
safer place than Japan or America Mexico
was safer back then give us your huddled
masses Asian food was okay they didn't
have the cartel yet you know oh yeah
dude I have you guys seen like any of
those docs on like the Mexican cartel in
type [ __ ] yeah it's it's tragic that
[ __ ] is easy met like I heard this story
from one of these guys that went to
Riverside with me he went to a Korean
Church and he came back kind of like
shook and he was telling me about this
Korean girl so she did her family went
to that church and they went on some
kind of Mexico mission trip but then the
the daughter was missing from the trip
and she got kidnapped I don't know if
you could even look this up if it's on
the news or something you might even be
able to look up this article but she got
kidnapped or somehow she got kidnapped
by cartel assumption I don't know what
area they went to but either way she got
kidnapped and the only way they were
gonna release her to give him an X
amount of money but they could only
raise half of the money and so they gave
her half the money gave them half the
money they lose all we had that I cool
so they they sent her back but they sent
half her bro like half her [ __ ] body
that's nasty
isn't that [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy do him
they don't [ __ ] play man it's rough
though I can't imagine living in a
country where you can't feel safe from
like anything and your government or
your community or anything like it's
just [ __ ] nuts man like the cops will
rob you corrupt yeah
I mean they say America's Cup and all
that but I'm like man I've actually been
to corrupt countries and it is and
that's why they're all running away here
yeah like it's it's different dude I
[ __ ] love America dude yeah go to a
cop and be like [ __ ] you ain't and then
nothing happens well depending on your
skin color a light in between I mean we
have our own set of problems but man is
I don't know I think it's just different
although I have to say Japan's a pretty
good competitor cuz its safest book yeah
I've never felt so safe in a country
besides toupee add like comparison say
you know what's in it there's a price
for that safety though you know what's
interesting though you know well because
when we went to Japan this this last
round we were in the countryside area
right people are way different than the
people in Tokyo Oh big time they don't
give a [ __ ] over there dude they're so
New York versus [ __ ] Sacramento yeah
you know like there's no like you know
remember when we were in Tokyo we had
this thing where a lot of us didn't know
which side of the the street to walk on
right so ongoing traffic this way and
the other one that goes the other way
and then there will be people who are
visibly upset that we didn't know that
yeah but then I was surprised when we're
gonna kill it though nobody gave up but
no white people although you guys are
lawless you [ __ ] Japanese [ __ ] and I
don't know why in Osaka too like they
wait on the right side of the escalator
so like everywhere else in Japan like
you know how on if you're on the left
side of the escalator then you you let
like people on the right just pass run
yeah if they're in a hurry same with
stairs or the slow people move to the
left right yeah but no sockets the right
it's always the right what the [ __ ] yeah
I don't know why yeah like I I find it
very odd because I even found some like
grumpy ass people like it's like first
of all the population Japan they're all
above the age of 80 like what the [ __ ]
is that about
all the construction workers were 80
years old there was strong as grandpa's
yeah where's the young people that man
they're just all old people working all
the young people are like in the
business this is like in the in the
offices and [ __ ] oh okay
because all the construction workers
were [ __ ] geriatric human being
you know oldest [ __ ] dude dude the
average age of the farm of a farmer out
there like it's 75 or some [ __ ] like
that when we went to our tea farm yeah
it was just a bunch of 80 year old
ladies picking [ __ ] individual tea
Lee yeah Wow and they were so short they
were standing up under the shade like I
had to crouch but they were standing up
straight just yeah they're like three
feet tall so anyways if we're the topic
today a very interesting question that I
don't think anybody's really asked me
before the question was what would you
do if one of your kids were born gay
that's a simple one kick them like I
mean your kid pops out and they're like
fabulous like really when they come out
like that's [ __ ] crazy is it just
because I think because all kids are
kind of to me all kids are kind of gay I
think it's like if they were born gay I
mean like should I just be used to it
from day one I'd be more surprised if my
son was hella like non there's no gay
signals right yeah I can in just all of
a sudden boom it's like oh [ __ ] you
coming out at like 35 years old or
something you know like I didn't know
man I had no idea it's like back in the
day I think it would have been more of a
I would have a lot more to think about
just because of based on my ignorance
and I've never really had to think about
it because in my mind if I had a kid
they were just gonna be heterosexual
right but I think now he's who the [ __ ]
cares yeah like I think I'd be more
upset if my kid came up and he was like
dad I'm gay and I just didn't want to
tell you I thought why the [ __ ] wouldn't
you want to tell me like what's wrong
with you I get my feelings her like
[ __ ] why can't you be open with me yeah
hmm it would be a very odd thing the
thing that I if I had any negative
emotion or it's not really negative but
if I had any like objection to it I'm
trying to think like the only thing that
would make me go oh man is I want my
genetics to pass on mmm
like there's just this weird I know
primal yeah like I want a [ __ ] Empire
you know like
yeah diced guys guess somehow I have
this theory in my head that the only way
I could reincarnate is back into the
program of my DNA mmm that's the that's
that's what I think so then might come
has to be in somewhere for me to come
back to this world so like you better
[ __ ] come in somebody I don't care if
you're gay I just like it coming
somebody in the move on yeah but I mean
so so if I had daughters and if I had
sons and then like like there was like
one gay kid then that wouldn't worry me
because I'm like it's cool I could come
back yeah [ __ ] I could come back in
one of your children yeah and one of
your kids off I can come back but then
like if I only have like one kid and
then I'll be like damn dude so I hope
technology is good enough to where if
you do get a husband you all could
[ __ ] pop out a kid somehow with our
if our genetics yeah yeah I'm I feel I
mean everybody talks about their there I
mean from the few gay friends that I do
have they talk about that coming up
moment as being a really huge thing but
I remember when I was young what one of
our friends younger younger brothers
came out to us right but we knew this
[ __ ] was gay since day one right
this dude was flamboyant as [ __ ]
[ __ ] walk around tossing his
hips around [ __ ] no [ __ ] British ass
saying down the [ __ ] kitchen is [ __ ]
I always wanted to be the sister when we
play house yeah I mean this mother gay I
know we I had a friend like that he
always wanted to be the mom a sister
yeah and I'm like hmm okay mmm so we're
all brothers not and I'll be the sister
and you know I think I I realized he was
gay when his favorite thing to do was to
kiss her the husband oh to go to school
to go to work so they were going in the
car okay bye honey
oh wait let me give you a kiss and then
he would kiss the boy and then [ __ ]
drive off and he would want to do that
to all the boys oh my god that's why he
always wanted to play though because I
want to drop everybody off yeah that's
I'm like this guy likes boys
boy yeah what this kid came out I
remember he got he got mad at us because
I I guess we kind of ruined his
coming-out moment but we kind of ruined
it and not in a bad way and my personal
opinion wasn't that because he came out
and he was just like seriously goes you
know my guys I just want to tell you
guys that um I have something heavy on
my chest and I think a for a while now
and then his brother looked at me goes
no [ __ ] [ __ ] dude no [ __ ] that we
all do why he's like get the [ __ ] out
the way like we're playing games to him
it wasn't big news right he goes yeah no
[ __ ] you know you're gay
you ruined my coming-out but we said you
can't come out we ready [ __ ] you were
gay hey that's like what the [ __ ]
you probably had this like epic
expectation like people be like really
we exert love you yeah oh it's like shut
up we've been accepting yeah
that's what his brothers mind-state was
he goes I've been accepting that you're
[ __ ] gay goes you honey because
you're not very good at hiding it yeah
he goes you know you don't think our
parents knew that you were gay like
you're they know they just never said
anything yeah I mean they but
everything's been the same you know mom
still gives you hugs and kisses dad
still loves you so what the [ __ ] you
know he was more like a game that
they've been playing around him exactly
they should be coming out like hey guess
what we've been pretty been not like
acknowledging that you were gay this
whole time yeah they were just waiting
for him just to be comfortable with it
himself you know but they'll just say
well [ __ ] it move on you know and he I
think he was just mad because we were
playing like we're playing at 2k
whatever I forgot it was quite a few
years ago yeah and then he was like
interrupting his game yeah we were just
watching look at the [ __ ] man I guess
that moment was supposed to be huge
wiping he still holds it against us but
until this day his brothers just like to
like nobody [ __ ] cares man I was like
I think you you don't know what family
are in our family is very accepting and
loving
that's so funny that's hilarious yeah he
was he still like salty about this and
you know what's funny is that now it's
so common to be gay that coming out
doesn't even seem as brave anymore well
it's still brave gonna do but it it's I
think it's lost
it's like wow
factor which is a good thing you know is
really [ __ ] yeah man in California I'm
pretty sure it maybe not such liberal
states right you're a very liberal and
open state like a Bible Belt state and
yeah and a very conservative family or
some [ __ ] you could get disowned and
[ __ ] yeah I worked with the girl who
onset and she was telling me her story
her father was actually this very famous
pastor out like in one of the Bible Belt
states and she's like super openly gay
is like a conversion camera something it
was like so they sent her to a gay camp
like a Christian gay camp or they're
trying to pray that gay virgin campaign
yeah I'm like how do you pray a [ __ ]
gay demon out of you do like the game
like that gay demon must be like just
like an exorcism that tends to push
about and the [ __ ] edema just come down
head which I think I will just leave
like what they do to try to exercise the
gayness out of the demon like they're
gonna be like alright what we're gonna
do is bad fashion we got some
[ __ ] pills those like whatever
like they got all these things that they
think that most ignorant should ever do
they think that the gay demon would be
like no I can't be around tackiness and
those colors don't work together I'm out
here baby yeah I don't know but she she
went to one of those conversion camps
and she said it was a blast because they
would just [ __ ] each other it's almost
like right
everybody together and they can [ __ ]
[ __ ] all day long yeah so what they
would do they would sneak off somehow
they would do it and they would just
[ __ ] each other all night and so she
said it was like the best time of her
life so everyone's pretending that
they're like yeah you know headed after
hours are like [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah cuz
they're like praying over them trying to
like exorcise them and all this other
stuff and just they're just waiting for
that moment at night when all the camp
counselors or whatever goes to sleep and
they would just start [ __ ] around
with it although people that are
volunteers and involved too are gay as
hell because usually people that are
hella homophobic or are [ __ ] that
would to the dopest [ __ ] movie
because they're like they're there and
they're sweating and they can't resist
because they want that [ __ ] bad but
then they're like so against being gay
cuz they're actually gay themselves but
then they see all these hot guys and
[ __ ] they're like oh my god and then
they can't take it anymore and then they
started like undercover like [ __ ]
that should it be tight dude that's what
I would do if I was them and I was
somebody who was really into like big
chicks sitting on my face I would just
join fat camp yeah what a better place I
know then that I didn't strategize well
enough like my dating pool see you know
what though I feel like gay guys just
have more fun it's with you know what I
found out I know this is how it sounds
so [ __ ] ignorant but we just talked
about like male aggression and how they
approach women dude [ __ ] gay guys
they approach gay males the same way
they approach women and it's kind of
uncomfortable if you've noticed that
[ __ ] like have you ever been like
sexually harassed by a dude I'm pretty
sure you have I work in West Hollywood
I've been hit on by guys but that's just
kind of aggressive super aggressive yeah
my first week we're gonna watch
Hollywood like I was going to a coffee
bean and the guy wanted to buy my coffee
like you just wouldn't he oh he opened
the door for me it was weird like I win
when guys try to hit on me I'm like nah
I [ __ ] you
I get myself in a bad situation because
I'm deep in conversation
you're not even game just leading me on
he doesn't know cuz I [ __ ] you alright
you don't [ __ ] me
stupid [ __ ] I'm not even gay I just
don't like to be [ __ ] controlled and
I just don't want to [ __ ] be
dominated dude [ __ ] it yeah like if I
had a gay kid its I feel number one
we're in California very liberal area I
don't I don't think it would I would bat
an eye at it there's no I don't even see
it as wrong that's why yeah it's
difficult for me to see who you want to
love as something that has anything to
do with morals yeah like it pedophilia
is the thing that makes sense yeah
because there is it's not two consenting
adults you know but if it's two
consenting adults right and it's like
let's say you're [ __ ] even there's
even relationships where there's like 70
year olds gaining with twenty year olds
yeah I call that a pimp in both
directions
yeah but also it's like it's it's odd
because you don't get it but if for them
they found somebody it's like so why
there's [ __ ] billions of people in
this world why do you have concern for
that pay your [ __ ] bills because
let's say if I have a because I even had
a conversation once about is it wrong to
want your kid to be heterosexual right
and that was a very interesting
conversation because I never really
thought about that really is it is it is
it wrong are you projecting something
that you want out of your kid that
obviously that you can't get if they're
if they're if they turn out to be gay
now for me I don't know that was such a
weird question because I didn't know how
to answer it because if somebody asked
me you know do you want your kid to be
heterosexual I feel like if I said yes
people would hate me for it well because
we're living in a highly sensitive gay
time yeah because for me okay everything
is very like y'all you should accept
them no matter what right but the way I
see it is like is it wrong to want your
kid to be a [ __ ] president yeah
because some people or tall yeah you
know some people have this feeling of
like
you know where they where they kind of
plan out their kids like we're imagine a
kids like right like I think if we look
at it black and white yes it's wrong
because you shouldn't expect anything
out of your kid and accept them to the
way they the way they are but we're all
human and I don't want my kid to be a
[ __ ] loser I want them to do well
yeah but being gay isn't a loser right I
don't want them to mix that up I'm just
saying there's gonna be expectations you
know mm-hmm and then and it doesn't mean
that if you want them to be hetero that
means like oh because I don't like the
gay [ __ ] you don't I mean like if I want
them to be tall it's not because short
is bad exactly so normal like it's
become so normal for me that I just look
at it as like a trait right so yeah I
would if I have a kid what I prefer to
be tall yes if I had a kid would I
prefer him not to have my bad eyes yes
if I had this kid would I prefer him at
the moment I think would I want a boy
over a girl like is that wrong right
wrong or right - and even now like
people who are having an issue with you
can't say whether you want a boy or girl
right you know what's the problem if you
just depends on what's what it's
motivated by yeah because some people
say it because like for example in China
right like like there was the one-child
policy and then they're hoping that it's
a boy because what ends up happening is
the boy would stay with the family and
take care of the family and in the girl
won't right yeah so that makes sense but
some people are like oh I don't want to
grow because they're [ __ ] they
[ __ ] complain too much yeah that's
bad yeah right
so I guess is for me its perspective on
where you grew up in how you live right
so some people might say if they didn't
grow up in a very liberal area I could
see why they would take they'd be very
sensitive to it but I feel like growing
up how we we have and what we're
surrounded with it's just more like you
can yeah I don't need somebody to
[ __ ] have a megaphone and blast it in
my face like oh by the way I'm gay so is
everybody else here alright move on you
know like nobody [ __ ] cares I would
say that I would want my kids to be
hetero but it's not the most important
thing in the world so for example let's
say my kid is hetero but but [ __ ]
complete loser
I and then then it that doesn't even
matter anymore cuz what's most important
to me is someone who's not a loser yeah
so like losers and bad traits like
scamming people [ __ ] you know
unsuccessful staying at home doing jack
[ __ ] and like you know I mean like
there's Oh like that sexual preference
for me
is like at the it's the least of my
worries yes it's a trait that's at the
bottom of the totem pole of how much I
care yeah you know but if you ask me the
question it's like yeah I do have a
preference but that's a preference you
know it's like big booty is a preference
for me this podcast was brought to you
by Fiverr my friends let's talk about
finding freelance talent for your
business or project where do you go to
find a talent how much will it cost how
can you be certain they'll deliver well
thanks to fiber finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
I have used Fiverr specifically for
graphic designs for album artwork and
let me tell you something people that
person was fantastic and let me tell you
something else
I got my stuff done on a timely manner
and let me tell you something else the
price was just right fibrous marketplace
connects businesses with freelancers who
offer hundreds of digital services
including graphic design copywriting web
programming film editing and more so
check this out take five and check out
Fiverr calm and you will receive 10% off
your first order by using my code brain
it's so easy don't waste any more time
and get the service you deserve by going
to five-0 com code brain again that's
fiverr.com code brain fi ve RR dot-com
code brain
I just choice I just I just want
hopefully I'm allowed to just crack
jokes at him all the time that's all I
want
so if you like say your kids
kindergarten ready you can just just a
free like Halloween and your son wants
to dress up as no Captain Marvel mm-hmm
that would be no problem are you
addressing whatever the [ __ ] you wanna
but I'm also allowed to make funny
if she were he dressed up as Captain
Marvel yeah cuz you look [ __ ] weird
that's all I would think in my
perspective you know like if he wanted
to be like a ballerina or something like
a ballerina yeah I mean there are Beller
you know but like I'm just saying like
you you see on like on Instagram like Oh
or like those stories about like my son
dressed up as that one character from
Bob's Burgers
but the glut the chick with the glasses
yeah you know it's such like a heroic
thing for the father sure like nurtured
that in like to notice that and know
that the pressures of like society
saying like that's gay but the father
like doubling down and being like I'm
accepting myself or however you wants to
be I don't know if I need to nurture
that I used to see if you want to play
dress address of where the [ __ ] you want
it's make-believe so make believe you're
a [ __ ] girl but if it's one of the
things were like he's like you know like
we know that you were gay we've seen all
the signs would you kind of just let it
be or kind of like well I'll take on the
responsibilities of I don't want to take
on that responsibility because I don't
know what it's like to be gay so it's
not my place to and also to on top of
that I want that kid to be able to
explore how he wants to explore it so I
feel like sometimes to some of these
parents because they're trying to be
hyper progressive they're putting their
agenda of wanting to be a progressive
parents like they're making their kids
gay even if they're straight yeah they
want to be so progressive like they're
like forcing their kids to be gay like
they'll see stuff like you sure you'll
like their kids playing play more with
boys like oh my kids probably I'm gonna
try to nurture that well you don't know
kids just play with kids let them be
kids they don't they're figuring out
like gender roles and they're figuring
out their preferences yeah because I
think it's odd for a parent to say I'm
gonna nurture their it either hetero or
homosexual side you don't you know their
kids let them explore they'll figure it
out you know and they were born gay then
they'll figure out when they're older
just you know you just you can't sit
there and try to control what their
sexual preference is at at that age it
goes both ways I think it's odd when a
parent goes oh you know he wants to
dress up as a girl whatever I'm gonna
try to nurture there's nothing to
nurture they're just kids like I dressed
up like a girl yeah I I put on [ __ ]
wigs and [ __ ] - did ya my parents didn't
stop me from doing it they didn't
torture anything man you know it's just
if it's in fact that we're sticking to
the to the fact that you were either
born heterosexual or born
a homosexual what's there to nurture hmm
there is no nurturing aspect to it right
because then now you're going against
what your belief is now you're saying
that okay well this is something that I
could call too but you shouldn't be able
to cultivate it because you think you
were talking you cultivate cultivate
gayness that's a yeah like especially if
you're straight yeah like if you if I
guess if you know the parents were gay
that makes sense you could cultivate
like a positive oh yeah gay kid that
lived that lives in a healthy gay world
or whatever like how do you be you know
operate you know as a gay person yeah
the parents would probably be able to
help that but straight parents I don't
know yeah and then now I mean I wouldn't
be absent but I also wouldn't try to
control and create something I just
don't want to be that person who's
number one speaking from uh not without
experience and on it and then try to
create this environment for them that I
think is positive based on something I
don't know about so for me if I see a
kid dressed up as a girl or you know
puts on makeup I just think that's a kid
just trying out some different [ __ ] so I
mean maybe we could see signs when you
know your kid because if you're a parent
and that's your child you could probably
see that sign where like is it to me
when I see a parent do that do I think
it's smart I don't think it is I think
that you should let a kid be a kid and
they'll be able to figure it out and
then when they need help then you can
help them but at that point they're so
young who's to say cuz I've seen a bunch
of like boy kids were their parents
heels but they're heterosexual kids they
didn't sit there and say like oh I could
tell this kid's gonna be he needs to
find himself so maybe I should nurture
this side what's there in a nurture you
don't know he's a child
mm-hm he or she's a child if the girl
wants to wear more boy clothes maybe
because it's more comfortable maybe
because she only has guy friends so she
sees that as something that she likes to
wear hmm we don't know these type of
things you don't know what's going on
these kids minds they don't know what's
going on that means the parents are just
homophobic maybe because they think
everything is gay it's like the person
that's so not right it's like they're
the ones that always say that they're
not racist you know that racist people
or the [ __ ] extra safe you have so
[ __ ] safe about racism people yeah
because they think it all the time you
know so I'm like I think that's a little
odd for me I don't know I don't know you
feel I think I mean it's out of line
because that leads me down to the line
of like the stories and it always breaks
my
I hear about it when the 13 year old kid
kills himself well they were gay and
they weren't extended in being bullied
yeah so like who wasn't like that's what
always bugs me in it being Pride Month
like these stories come out again I just
get reminded of that and just kind of
like how can we better help I guess
nurture is not the right word but just
kind of like exception acceptance to
have a space and just like an emblem
know so they don't have to keep it a
secret and hold it because you say like
I'd be so disappointed or so sad if my
son was gay he tells me he's 35 yeah and
for him not to feel comfortable not
telling you that yeah every family is
different to run every totally group I
think in California it feels like it
almost feels like you're wrong if you're
against gays in California yeah yeah um
but maybe it feels different in other
places you know because I I do remember
it wasn't too long ago even in
California like just being gay was like
like bad like are you gay fool yeah I
mean it's funny to say it yeah because
you didn't mean gay but then also I
think there's like a lot of humor in it
just just just watching a guy like
there's you know there's comedy in
people going beyond what's expected
right so if a guy acts like a girl
that's funny or girl acts like a guy
it's funny because that's not what
you're supposed to do it right so now
they're trying to change that supposed
to mmm yeah so anyone can act like
anyone yeah but also I'm very immature
yeah so it's not that you know I'm
malicious about it but I think it's
funny still yeah I don't know I think
it's funny it's if a guy acts like a dog
or like a like I don't know like it's
all funny to me yeah even if an adult
acts like a kid it's like when you're I
don't know when it's when it's when
people are acting you know I guess
they're against traditional expectations
to me it's just [ __ ] hilarious yeah I
don't know even you know what though I
make fun of everything so I'm not a good
person
- yeah gauge things off this is such a
weird thing for me to articulate yeah
because I
number one I just don't think about it
it's not something that it's not to
sound crass to say I don't care as in I
don't care about any of these type of
subjects it's just more like if it
happens all right cool there's nothing
it's it's almost like asking what would
you do if you found out your kid had
eyeballs yeah I guess yeah I don't see
it as a wrong trait I just think I can't
wait to make fun of them yeah stupid
lives but that's that's true with
everything yeah like even if my kid was
straight I can't wait to make fun of
that [ __ ]
yeah he's gonna do something funny
that's funny to me yeah and I don't know
it that's why it's hard for me to say
because some people joke with malicious
intent yeah I joke because I'm immature
yeah it's cool though how how I've been
even the other day I was eating at this
a Peruvian joint and the dude that came
up that was [ __ ] pretty as [ __ ] yeah
he was a prettiest [ __ ] boy we've
ever seen in our life this one came up
all makeup done and everything and I
just looked at him like man the world
has changed huh like in a good way I was
like you could just walk around be like
that and nobody say [ __ ] to him dude
like he's open enough and he's kind of
comfortable in California anyways for
him to walk around and it's just more
like I'm like look at that you know and
he could just walk around and be himself
and that's pretty [ __ ] cool dude yeah
I know but he was hella seductive too so
he was like a gay seductive he's pretty
I'd like makeup on and yeah yeah the
[ __ ] pretty ass face right and then
he's all like are you guys ready - yeah
[Laughter]
like I don't know why you said it like
that but are you guys done with your
pilate's yeah so smooth like sultry yeah
but I mean I to me it's funny it's IIIi
don't know why you can't laugh at it I
think I don't know it's not like I'm
laughing because I hate to do yeah like
you know it's it's it's just it's
different still until it's very common
and I I actually want more of it to
happen if that's who you really are but
that's who you feel comfortable with
right by by being but that's but the see
I don't want people to get it mixed up
from that and me making fun of someone
because they're wearing funny pants yeah
or their hair was funny that day I think
the humor is just isn't it's the fact
that it's something that you don't see
normally right yeah so that's that's
really what it is but one day it will be
normal now but and then it won't be
funny anymore because it's everywhere
yeah yeah yes the goal right it's hard
being sometimes like an outlier and
accepting that you are in an outline I
want say outline is the word but you're
just you're just different from the
current social norm right so there's a
there's a big cross to bear with that
meaning that you have to kind of take on
that responsibility right now yeah and
the way society is with people having to
look at you a little different and you
having to go that extra step and explain
to people you know why you are the way
that you are and you know taking these
funny looks I mean that's just for any
type of generation like there was a time
where specifically I do even Asians yeah
like us existing was funny to people
like just walking around people would
just laugh at me because I'm Asian and I
have Mexican kids [ __ ] do Chinese
eyes just and start cracking up because
they probably didn't see many Asian kids
yeah I mean so but I was just like
progress all I'm normal yeah
and if they see a lot more Asians
they're gonna it's not gonna be funny
anymore yeah I just don't think it's
like I said this is coming from my
perspective of it's just it you're gonna
have to be a strong person for now to
deal with it but you know as as you are
who you are and you are putting yourself
out there for people to see and your
kind of normalizing these things you're
just setting up for a more positive
generation to happen after you so as of
right now you just have to bear that
cross if you want to be the change that
you want to see in the future yeah so
and there's a lot of people that had to
do that I mean it for our case too when
we came onto YouTube just having Asian
people on the screen doing like crazy
[ __ ] like this or even an Asian person
cursing or not like [ __ ] crunching
numbers and [ __ ] was odd to people this
was only [ __ ] like eight years ago
it blew people's minds like oh my god
you're not [ __ ] serving Chinese food
this is not even a decade ago and it was
blowing people's mind you know I'm
saying like even me say a phrase like
you know what I'm saying they would be
like oh why are you trying to sound
black this was only eight years ago so
it takes time for these seems to happen
in Chisholm I think it just takes strong
individuals to really be that beacon of
light yeah you know and I support them
because I'm an oddball yeah and I know
what that I live it every day but I I
think you know I also support them to
make fun of everything in anything
because that makes the world a better
place
III I'd like that about comedy that you
could anybody can be made fun of that
any given or whatever you know I think
it becomes sad when things were just oh
you're not allowed to touch the space
anyways yeah comedy space I say you just
leave it let people also let people be
offended though you're that's fine just
don't censor that part yeah that's true
I mean we don't have progress unless we
open our mouths yeah got to do it I've
always let people be offended let people
get mad that's completely fine I'm cool
with it
to be honest with you it's just when
they have this thing like for example
where Twitter's trying to censor all
these like specific things that's going
to offend people I have an issue with
that
yes silencing is very different yeah
yeah because people don't have the
opportunity to change either and learn
and I yeah this podcast was brought to
you by purple have you ever woken up in
a puddle of your own sweat have you ever
woken up and you were like man I thought
I slept ten hours
but it only felt like I slept like one
well it's because you don't have a
purple mattress my friends yep I have a
purple mattress Cho has a purple
mattress yeah and let me tell you
something every day
my back whispers to me thank you David
thank you for blessing me with purple
mattress material because I'm talking
about it feels great
I'm saying it feels great to wake up
refreshed once in my life I've been told
my whole life as a Asian kid that I
should sleep on rocks and firm beds and
apparently it's really bad for your back
but purple mattress has saved my life
that's right and the purple mattress
will probably feel different than
anything you've ever experienced because
it uses this like brand-new material
that was developed by an actual get this
rocket scientist and it's really not
like the memory foam that I used to use
and the purple mattress feels really
unique because it's both firm and soft
and at the same time it keeps everything
supported while feeling like really
comfortable and like you said it's
breathable so it sleeps cool so here's a
really cool part of it okay so there's a
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund that means
you could sleep for a hundred nights and
just return it if you don't like it and
it's backed by a 10-year warranty that's
pretty cool and there's free shipping
and returns and free in-home setup an
old mattress removal this is just
amazing
so check it out you're going to love
purple and right now our listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four - eight eight the only way to
get this free pillow is to text the
brain to eight four - eight eight eight
that's B R a I n - eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply yeah it's it's such a weird weird
thing where I see that on Twitter where
I forgot what was trending but you know
Twitter's trying to censor anything
that's offensive and it's just a very
poor representation of what life is and
that's the same problem that I have with
a younger generation which I'm pretty
sure our older generation said that
about us
where they're just being coming soft
like you just don't want to hear bad
things that's life you're always gonna
hear bad things and mind you like the
the the medium that you're hearing these
negativity the the negative stuff and
the negativity is coming from a very
specific source now but you also have
that option as a person to not be on
that platform and nobody takes that
option they go well I'm on Twitter I
have to see this you don't have to be on
Twitter I think that might be a little
hard because saying that might be
telling us you don't have to have a
telephone you know it's a piece of the
society today to have to talk on Twitter
or to talk on Instagram
I feel like Twitter's a little more
visceral because it's just words right
so I know I know like YouTube you can
watch a video be entertained yeah you
know or you can do stuff like Instagram
yeah that stuff right and choose to not
look at these comments but Twitter darts
are specifically made to read words so
there's no escape from that yeah so that
platform for me it's just just choose
not to be a part of that or you could
choose not to follow certain people
that's true that's what I do yeah I
choose not to follow people that I feel
are toxic yeah and don't don't feel like
blocking people as a sign of weakness
because I block people for fun all the
time you know it's it's almost like
that's true it's a sport for me now
people you know you block them because
you have nothing else to say to them no
you're right because they're dumb the
conversation yeah and sometimes they're
just trolled and you'd want them to go
through the job of making a new account
yeah and then you block them right away
and they have to make another account
for sure I know I know like you you're
always in like the West Hollywood area
yeah it's not a stir if you guys haven't
been to LA like there's a huge gay
community in the West Hollywood exactly
yes definitely what they should say
about San Francisco it's like the Castro
district it's like the butthole
it's okay yeah I mean for me so she
never would have you know initially
wanted to become Abascal you know
playing the NBA set play semi-pro quit
being an actor get survivor job working
in West Hollywood and then see what
that's all about and then having these
my all my co-workers be gay and I'm the
only straight guy so every time it's
like a joke like when Easter comes
around like they make fun of you now
they make fun of me yeah I'm the guy
like out there like try and think of
like they're like think about like
painting the room you know the office
and like a crew like the color crew and
what the [ __ ] is that they're like you
don't want Chris I'm like no it's like
oh don't worry you're not gay
it's like totally fine you know you're
the odd one right so like my boss is
like super sweet and he'll give us like
you know cookies or whatever from air1
or something and like it's all like
Easter eggs and then like one chick you
know and like Kelly guess which one's
yours I'm like the chick yeah cuz you
like girls it's like yeah okay cool [ __ ]
like bowling us you know so a hetero
[ __ ] they start [ __ ] punking you is
[ __ ] now yeah it's just mob mentality is
what it is I don't even think it's a gay
or a hetero things it's just a different
people like to pay maggiore that's the
minority yeah the majority always
crushes the minority it's so [ __ ]
funny
yeah yes every time so every time for
lunch I always heard about my co-workers
like Grindr stories it's just so
interesting like just learning about the
world and like bottoms and power bottoms
and like all this [ __ ] like what
scolding crap and just show me like what
they'd say it's like dick pics I'm like
yo this is crazy
and like 17 year old click Khalif was
kind of like i mean he was because the
majority I was like home I want to say I
was homophobic I just thought was just
funny
well I you know fight [ __ ]
homosexuality the black community is is
yeah that's taboo like it's super tablet
yeah yeah me you get beat up jump in all
of this yeah I mean my even my I'm
putting down blast he's like I don't
mind if they're gay just don't [ __ ] me
it's like that whole mentality is that
okay and why would they want to fight in
the first place it's like ugly as [ __ ]
to you someone's gay they're gonna be
like oh my god you're gonna try to [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of all of us is a stupid my
day gay they just can't get this as yeah
yeah it was like what's the [ __ ] you
would you know you don't
yeah I'll play varsity yeah I always
find so fast especially this month being
pride and just like it's such a
beautiful thing seeing everyone and just
on the streets and really embracing that
that was a we I didn't know we had a
Asian Pride Month oh is it like last
month asian asian
yeah it's like March or April yeah it's
always to be Asian that's why I hope but
you know I'm just gonna say this but
like there's a lot of [ __ ] agents out
there in one whole month I don't know
we need a [ __ ] to Japan Montana RIA
Montana let's start off did you guys
even come across an article about like
this petition for a straight Pride Month
I don't think we need that I think
should no devil is a great title yeah
straight pride this entire lose starting
to fish I don't know I think it's a
funny joke I think that's funny that's
funny yeah it's a joke but no someone's
like started its called Valentine's Day
yeah people are serious about I don't
think they understand why people have
these months is because it's to
represent a minority right so it's to
give a minority a time to shine yeah
because white people recognize every
[ __ ] day yeah that's why you don't
need white Pride Month you know because
every day is white pride - oh it's just
a lot it's to allow a minority to be
happy and I lied and highlighted and
history she ate a appreciate yeah you
know that's like something that doesn't
happen on the regular that's why there's
Black History Month there's Asian
Heritage Month there's you know Pride
Month that's that's why we have these
things it's not to say like oh we're
gonna be [ __ ] I may in your [ __ ]
face it's more like you let us just let
us shine first year history because
white people live in a bubble a white
bubble and they could just listen to
white content watch white white things
and they will not even know that
minorities really exists
in America and I learned that from Jess
you know like she she's she told me that
yeah like when she was a kid she grew up
like pretty I guess like not so well in
a community of blacks and Mexicans or
whatever like like it was like
multicultural but it was like the
welfare like housing center right so mmm
when she moved out to Texas she she grew
up in an all-white town and then the
only minority there was like a couple of
Mexican kids but a lot of them also were
kind of Americanized yeah you know and
then so she didn't really know she
didn't really know like really what the
outside world thought of white people
you know she had no idea
uh-uh she didn't know that there was
still like you know issues or anything
she institutionalized racism she thought
it was just like oh that was the 60s you
know but thank God we got over all that
so with that mentality I can see how
there's a lot of white people that just
don't know because they're like I
thought that was over with no cuz they
live in a little area that's there's a
bubble they don't they don't and this is
the first time in history where we have
the ability to talk to them online and
show rectly yeah and see how we feel
about them and all that stuff there's
almost a sense of denial sometimes even
though there's I'm it's hard to cuz
media likes to twist a lot of things too
so there's a lot of distrust and
narrative so it's like well how much of
this is you know how much of this is
false and you know it's it's hard for us
not to use personal incidents as a way
of evidence you know because it's its
bias right also in white culture -
they're not collective like Asians or
minorities are more collective culture
right so for them it's like well like
what does a white guy in Indiana have
anything to do with some white guy in
[ __ ] Arizona mm-hmm that's that guy
that's you know that dude that was
racist to this black guy has nothing to
[ __ ] do with me mm-hmm
you know so why should he be responsible
for that but yeah we
live with the burden of oh man this
[ __ ] Asian guy on the news don't make
us look bad don't make us look bad like
all of us carry the weight of our
culture yeah we shouldn't but that's
just the effect of that's true you know
when you say that that's how I think all
the time when we were traveling I
mentioned this [ __ ] I just saw a bunch
of Chinese tourists I was like don't you
[ __ ] be a stereotype and without fail
they're always a stereotype that's like
don't you dare [ __ ] piss in that bag
and throw it on the floor
don't you dare [ __ ] on that newspaper
leave it there I'm like Korean person
dude don't you dare [ __ ] just start
beating your wife in public tell all of
our non Asian friends like no no no no
look there's a difference like does that
that's Koreans they do that so what are
you talking about like Korean people do
that all right
Japanese people cheat on their wives
yeah it's always interesting like did
you believe when they do like those
levels
aspera hello almost hi hello hello yes
Mario you want to pop into the camera
say hi show your face that's ray that's
ray races laughing in the corner baby
yes perfect I'll oh your hair looks cute
I like it looks refreshing
thanks for so it was so long before yeah
we're recording she doesn't give up and
they start buzzing us in that was asked
I called you me and Ray
we heard you but really understand it we
heard you we just got scared and this
anything because we thought we rang them
don't rot please wait wait so what were
you talking about the Jubilee what how
did you believe when they say like oh
all you need you believe project you
believe yeah yeah like it I always find
it so fast in cuz like they get big cars
so millions and millions of views and
like I always look at the de likes and
dislikes and like are all Asians are
like are all gays are like the anti Pro
it's a the spectrum it just goes back to
like all do all why people think alike
and it's so interesting when they pick
these people in weird boxes to all yeah
somebody tweeted that like the other day
when we were when I was asking first
for this podcast he'll do a video about
East Coast ages vs. West Coast ages I
just go I scroll what does that mean
this ain't us bro they seen a Fung bro
brother I look like a [ __ ] loser to
you did [ __ ] like it's such a dumb thing
I hate it when [ __ ] Asian people they
should let that dude it's so [ __ ]
annoying dude it's like Asian you know
this person inverses that Asian look
what does that mean yeah why crane that
what are you creating it doesn't even
exist you're creating these
subcategories that don't [ __ ] exist
it makes it look bad it makes us look
terrible then again you know you know
I'm not dogging on that guy that I'm
pretty sure it was a very innocent
question but for me it's a pet peeve of
mine but it's like tribalism yes and
it's in its you create monoliths out of
[ __ ] like you got to think of people as
individuals yeah and then sure there
might be some observed similarities
which is okay but you can't categorize
and be like and write people off be like
oh you're a liberal oh you're
conservative and yes you're this nice I
don't want that yeah I want people to
speak their mind and everyone has their
own type of you know stories and there
are similarities but everyone's got to
be represented as individuals cuz I got
a bunch of because and the reason why
that doesn't resonate with me cuz I got
a buncha Asian homies out in New York I
don't know the diff they're just people
like they're the same thing we just use
different slang this is you this shoe
this shoe yeah it was what's going on be
your own video issue yeah yeah fam what
else what else what I was in New York
slang [ __ ] what's up fam what's up B
this shoe [ __ ]
Oh take a cat sushi take it yes yeah
yeah yeah I don't know any New York
stuff me crazy
I just know Hawaii you know oh yeah brah
well look at that time time is up now
you're gonna go gets almost muscle baby
bra and let you go home yeah you sound
drunk well you know thanks for asking
that question once again that's a
perspective from three hetero guys so I
don't I don't really know once again
we're in California we're in a very
liberal state so when you ask that
question it's kind of hard for us to
fish for an answer because to me that
wouldn't really
matter it is what it is I guess it
wouldn't be ideal it's not important
yeah that not important as in it doesn't
matter it's it's not something that is a
concern a moral wrong or right a concern
about today because it exists man it's
existed in history it's it's a part of
being human and in I I don't think
people should deny that yeah yeah well
guys catch us on iTunes spot mail ask
those questions again that was actually
a hard one usually I have like a pretty
solid answer for things this one is
actually it's cuz it's not our world man
it's not a world is we don't think about
it I gotta bring one of the gay homies
in I gave I got gay friends but I never
got really close to any like gay
acquaintances right yeah I never got
really closely and I have a ton
different ages bring him all and they
could talk about though it was guys
catch us on Spotify iTunes all that
other good stuff yeah and give us that
five star leaving the comments below
some other topics or question that you
guys wants to want to ask us the more
difficult the better because you just
that fly on the wall listen to all these
conversations baby well you could catch
Khalif at Kelly Boyd on Instagram he is
an actor and also a penis model I am
yeah okay guys DM only everybody baby
haha I'll see y'all next time please